[Musique]
l'activité bilby aujourd'hui c'est
pratiquement 40% de l'ensemble de notre
de notre chiffre d'affaires nous
proposons différents types de matériels
les rangs pour pouvoir effectivement
accéder des appareils qu'ils ont pour
moi pouvoir permettre de franchir des
escaliers dont il monte escalier lorsque
le bâtiment est dépourvu d'ascenseur cas
de panne d'ascenseur en cas d'
d'évacuation d'urgence ou d'un incendie
nous disposons également de chaises
l'évacuation qui vont permettre à des à
des collaborateurs à des collègues
d'évacuer par les escaliers de façon
extrêmement simple des collaborateurs
qui sont en situation de handicap
[Musique]
pour des structures plus petites
petit surtout pme et tpe j'irai c'est
plutôt la volonté des managers ou des
dirigeants qui vont faire que les choses
vont évoluer
[Musique]